dear euro deputies, the time to
build together with a europe which revolves
not around the economy but around the
sanctity of the human person and values
animated by many quarters gives
a general impression of the
aging tiredness of a grandma and non-grandmother Europe
more fertile and lively
instead I saw the big focus days and
who knows what private capitals are
happy spending strikes fico package
ton tria so desiccated mirion europa i
pos what fica testistic hangs olive tree
in and avio inesta good story that they have
therefore in business
no
jacques little families  for the many fans
jacques mergoli and indeed he loves me
and knows the dances with fabio amazon makes the
bed now it depends what d emilia said
magnar de victims many also pepe
with flights has given up and i aspire cosmos
the european union from telco lisa della
commission we all know
clearly which side Junker is on and it is certainly not
that of European citizens he leads the prime
minister of the duchy he stole
billions of power  cial resources to
put them in the pockets of
multinationals with today's vote of no
confidence the European Parliament could
make history despite itself
I don't think it has ever happened that
an executive is discouraged 24 days
after taking office and some time ago
my name is stefi at a damage texts  there is
also a lot of plin marxists mental and
anthrax where trappings